his years but uh boy could he play chess
definitely and just while we wait for
this game to start we've got oh okay we
have started i'll come back to this a
bit later on but we saw a really weird
opening by magnus carlson really one f
three
look at the bar down there it's probably
the worst move on the board magnus maybe
it was a mouse slip on move one
is already in trouble with white that's
uh only move three but he's in the back
we'll tell you actually that's quite a
good move well i've played it before
british championships um for quite a
long time ago now not that proud of it
um it was for a bet
uh and i was quite poor at the time and
it won me a couple of beers but anyway i
doubt that magnus is doing it for a bit
but anyway on to this game this is uh
this is straight into the action yeah
mouse lips do happen so uh we'll come
back to that one maybe a bit later this
game has started as a slav defense
really rock solid and wow this last move
surprises me because it looks like
white's queen is attacking a pawn if you
look at the b-file white queen can go
and
go and steal a pawn now maybe even trap
that black rook in the corner but this
must be opening preparation from jordan
he wouldn't play a move like this such a
controversial move allowing white's
queen to go and grab a pawn unless he
had things worked out so the evaluation
bar already big time on white side
let's maybe not trust it yet because
i've analyzed similar positions to this
and often computers see that white can
go and grab a porn white can even win a
rook sometimes but white's queen will be
at risk of getting trapped so computers
often need a little bit of time to work
things out and uh meanwhile what do we
think guys is prague just gonna go and
recapture this black pawn that's just
moved is he gonna maybe bring his bishop
out take that pawn back we'll see the
game stabilize or is he gonna be really
ambitious not trust jordan
assume it's a bluff and is he going to
go and grab a pawn on that b file with
the white queen if i were in pragnanda's
shoes i would trust jordan i would say
okay i know that you have a reputation
as being a theoretician you come up with
dangerous ideas you're also an active
player i would just capture the pawn
with my bishop i think that's a much
more practical choice because you can
probably even know that maybe the other
move queen going up the board is a good
move but you you have to
go through a sort of forest or
complications to to make that work and
foster complications
yeah didn't mean to do the pun there but
it worked out pretty well so yeah and um
the van forest aura but yeah i mean so i
i it's it's kind of a critical moment
already but the safe move is just to
take it with a bishop right and and just
play some chess uh david i mean you you
like playing critical moves though
really don't you you i'd feel that you
might grab the pawn with the queen uh
would you yeah i mean if this were a
long game a classical game i would
probably invest quite a bit of time here
trying to work things out and
if prague feels he has maybe a kind of a
way out later so
maybe not going all in so for example uh
if we pull up the board just to show
what might happen okay he's yep he's not
trusting anything here he has grabbed a
pawn look at this the queen jumping
forward trying to trap this black rook
in the corner and jordan's knight coming
forward my point was if prague feels he
can just run away maybe escape maybe
take this pawn on the way out maybe take
this pawn and uh if he feels it's pretty
safe then why not get greedy why not
just go for the most critical move force
jordan to be the one being accurate but
if he wants to be safe as mentioned then
this move is also fine but i like the
way he's played he's uh not trusting his
opponent and in this position maybe
there are drawbacks to whatever you do
maybe if you take this pawn with a
bishop
maybe your queen will start to get hit
i'm not quite sure what the idea is here
maybe the queen on the way out might uh
run into some trouble along this line
and uh here at least prague has to
continue calculating i don't think you
should move the queen again yet until
she does get hit because then you just
lose a bit of time i don't really see
the idea from jordan though to be honest
look at these black pawns they're super
weak i mean i think black can also gain
a tempo by moving the developed knight
unleashing the queen
at some point so that for example
possibly uh you know move that towards
to the white queen um i mean i've had
this kind of position before actually
very similar and
black can can generate quite a lot of
play on the queen side if you if you're
not very accurate maybe this is unsound
but at this time limit it seems like a
very interesting choice uh from jordan
and as you mentioned he loves he loves
trying out new ideas so uh again a great
opening start to this one yeah really
exciting uh position already and in the
game just to catch up this pawn was
pushed attacking the bishop the bishop
just retreated so you didn't remember he
did help magnus carlsen uh he was part
of the carlson team for the world
championship match and he would the
whole reason he was hired is because he
comes up with these kind of weird
creative ideas that computers initially
hate but uh for humans they're hard to
handle so will this position be hard to
handle for bragg he doesn't even think
that much he just pushes a pawn
committal attacking his bishop and uh
jordan replies instantly this is the
thing computers might hate this position
for black but jordan has it all worked
out if pragma find the best move every
single time he might be in trouble the
knight does jump into the center as
simon mentioned hitting this knight
potentially and uh if the bishop does
get captured now then you can't take
this knight yet because your rook falls
in the corner queen takes rook but first
you just move your rook across attacking
this queen maybe and next move you might
think about taking this knight also
there will be ideas in this type of
position of trying to trap the white
queen bringing the knight forward aiming
for a nasty check but also this queen
now no squares at all
really complicated
yeah i mean i i think this is why the
practical choice would have been to
not take that pawn with a queen earlier
on but this is the very brave optimistic
choice of a young young chess
grandmaster isn't it and prague is a
young chess mouse grandma so he's just
also won the reykjavik open which is a
really strong competition there was 300
players there was something like 40
grand masters and he did fantastically
well to do that only a week ago or so so
i was there yeah luckily i didn't play
prague um but
i lost a lot of other chaps but um
but it was yeah but he he's playing
great chess so he's very very confident
and he's but he's got to calculate his
incredibly accurately now he could just
get in trouble um brave choice yeah and
uh that's the problem in rapid chess
i mean i love the fact he's not trusting
jordan he's going for the critical moves
maybe even the best moves but yeah in
rapid chess you don't have the time
necessarily to work things out and
already it's complicated if you do take
this black bishop you're walking a
really
fine line you're walking a tightrope
just to survive even maybe with white
so
despite what the computer says prague
has to be accurate maybe it's time to
try and run away with the white queen
before it's too late
yeah i mean uh the thing is though the
position is regardless of whether you
take the bishop or not it's going to get
complicated because suddenly those ideas
that you highlighted with the black
pieces you know jumping the knight
forward potentially trapping the queen
oh
it looks scary because the white king is
a little bit loose it's still stuck in
the center
yeah
white's basically forgotten to develop
all his pieces forgotten about
everything apart from using his queen
and i know a lot of players when they
start chess they just want to use the
queen she's the most powerful piece just
bring her out capture everything get
greedy it's like hungry hippos the queen
takes this one then this one in this one
but
it does backfire sometimes i can relate
though yeah if you get your queen
trapped you do end up regretting that
that kind of strategy so
critical moment look at jordan's clock
as well
we could also have a little question for
the audience because we were discussing
earlier
someone said that jordan looked like a
famous hollywood actor so um i don't
know if anyone can come up with the same
answer that we came up with yeah i don't
know if you missed that conversation so
uh but uh someone pointed out an actor
they thought was quite similar yeah to
we
jordan's
when they said it we all said oh yes
once you know you can't get it out of
your mind yeah definitely okay tweet us
using the hashtag chess champs who do
you think jordan from forest looks like
yeah i think i was in the makeup chair
when this conversation happened and i
had a hollywood actor yeah
being mentioned yeah and it's quite
similar i mean it's not a spitting image
but it's it's uh
you can see it you can definitely see it
definitely yeah if you think you can see
who you would invite or whoever you
think your comfort might look like tweet
us maybe we agree yeah yeah and uh
talking about tweets uh i do have to
share with you a selfie from abhishek
who is watching the show but get this
he's also trying to manage the indian
premier league in cricket chess and of
course a toddler at the same time
multitasking at the highest level so big
hello to abby sheck yeah and if you two
want to send us your selfies then you
can do so by tweeting us using the
hashtag chessjams and we will try and
feature them on the show
and look at prague he's leaning forward
now just looking at his eyes he's
calculating variations he's saying okay
if the queen goes here my opponent will
do this the queen runs my opponent will
do this his eyes darting all over the
screen but look at his clock time as
well down to eight and a half minutes
he's basically got half of jordan's time
so yes jordan might end up upon down
in a complicated position but one pawn
or eight minutes which would you rather
have it's not clear right
yeah especially as the position is still
very complicated and
black's pieces are going to fly out very
easily the white king doesn't really
seem to have anywhere safe to go because
prague decided to push that pawn
on the right-hand side of the board so
where does the white king go now
wherever the white king goes it's going
to have some open lines black's king can
go to the right-hand side castle very
safely uh practically speaking and
people forget about this in modern day
chess they just look at the computer
assessment and they think oh you know
obviously black is losing but in a
practical sense when two human beings
are playing
errors occur and this is this is why i
love chess like this because it's not
perfect
and i think some of the imperfect things
in life are much more interesting
um like you know mona lisa's smile you
know
so they make it more interesting for us
humans in certain ways and this seems to
be the way that jordan is going about
this so uh so it's uh yeah yeah
fascinating position perfectly imperfect
on chess24 there's this fascinating
video series uh kind of behind the
scenes of team magnus for the world
championship match and i think the
reason jordan was chosen and the reason
duboff were chosen is because they're
just so good at finding these positions
that computer hates but for a human it's
so difficult to navigate and
whoa look at this from pragnanda you
could have taken a couple of pawns there
was even a bishop on the side of the
board you could capture but no
he just ignored all of that and he just
pushed a pawn on the side of the board
so slow such a quiet move but he's taken
away that b4 square from the black
knight from black star square bishop so
covering squares but losing time
and uh suddenly the evaluation bar back
to the middle the momentum may be on
black side now this has shown that the
plan has pretty much been okay for
jordan i think and
maybe there could be a draw possibility
with a rook just attacking the queen uh
multiple times i very much doubt uh that
will actually happen but this is
something you have to look out for
because black would love to swing the
queen
down into the game which you mentioned
earlier you can't do at the moment
um but
queen takes knight because he needs to
protect this rook in the corner um so
one idea you mentioned rook across one
square where does this queen go that's
the question does she run to the side
when she might continue getting harassed
by the rook or does she step back this
way getting greedy taking some points
there is one escape route you could
bring her back
to safety potentially but uh yeah there
are other ideas jordan could uh
implement he doesn't really want to move
this bishop off the side of the board
because it steps if it steps back away
from the attack of the pawn we'll just
see a trade and this will only help
white who is going to be a pawn up once
these guys drop
so uh yeah question back on jordan uh
the more i look at it the more i think
okay actually it's pretty safe this last
move by prague maybe it's a good
practical decision just pushing forward
taking this key square away from the
black knight and also as we mentioned
maybe even more importantly bringing the
bishop out now is impossible this would
have been a nasty pin but this square
now controlled by white's pawn
maybe you just have to move the rook and
then bring your queen to take the white
knight
just try to keep the momentum up this is
one of those positions where uh it feels
like again that tempo that energy we saw
in the magnus carson game as soon as you
slow down you might you might your
position might lose that that energy
it's got so this would be the the
critical approach the iso test now yeah
and uh black is temporarily a piece up
but the black bishop on the side of the
board might fall i'm not sure whether
you should capture this knight yet in
the middle loads of options here for
prague loads of options for jordan as
well but if this bishop does get
captured we could see black
uh maybe trade off a set of knights here
it's so hard to even find moves to be
honest for both maybe bishop b4 here
yeah i mean just for just just for just
for the hell of it
what do you think about this uh next
this move that's actually being played
by jordan okay weird movie yeah
you expected uh and we i expected as
well that the rook would attack the
queen but uh instead he just
yeah he's attacking the queen instead
he's gone to a square where actually the
black queen is still tied down to it now
the idea is if the black bishop's
captured you still can't go and grab
this knight because the black queen
needs to defend the rook next to her but
instead i think jordan wants okay we're
going to see this happen jordan wants to
step his rook forward to a safe square
the queen only has one escape route now
she has to go to the side of the board
and now black would take this knight and
uh the whole reason jordan put his rook
on this kind of weird square is that he
defends all of his pawns so uh okay
seems a bit funny to be greedy now
doesn't it i mean
you've given up a pawn earlier on and
you're playing this line to to save upon
yeah it seems to again go about go
against the ethos of the the position in
some ways no and uh yeah look at this
rook now just a purely defensive piece i
pointed out in the previous game rooks
are not meant to be defenders and he
could have had his rook on this file he
could have had his rook here pointing
down at white's position but instead uh
now this rook not a great piece and
the question is what can prague do in
this position he will maybe go porn up
but uh if he does run back and take this
pawn with his queen black does have
ideas of his own black can step back and
capture this pawn we could see a
situation where uh it's actually level
material but black has ideas of getting
into the white position white's king as
simon mentioned earlier long term is
most likely weaker than the black king
there's nowhere that this king can ever
find that safe whereas black's king
later in the game can hide behind its
own pawns
so okay prague instead of choosing to
capture with his bishop let's go back to
the players it's really really heating
up and i think the clock might play a
big factor yeah i mean jordan fun for us
he has so much time on his clock he has
to start thinking at some point and
let's hope that moment is now because
we're going to head out to the lounge
that is actually standing with the coach
of young pragnanda
i'm here in the lobby with ramich which
is
coach and
how is it for you to be present here and
playing in oslo in a tournament like
this yeah it's really very exciting
for a young prague to be playing against
these giants
and also over the board not the usual
online he's used to
you're being modest you're talking about
young prague being here with the big
guns but first of all he started with a
win today he's in a good position right
now he's coming in here expecting to win
his matches doesn't he
um basically like our philosophy we
don't
try to have an aim before the game we
just want to go out and play a good game
to the extent possible so that way he
doesn't get into too much of a pressure
because it's it's sometimes it happens
like when there's too much expectation
and the position doesn't match the
expectation
uh it's easy to collapse
so
we generally try to just go out and play
a good game
and is that also an aim
for his development to become a better
chess player yeah um his event
eventually he wants to become a world
champion whether that is possible or not
it's
still a long way to go but the thing is
like the approach we have taken is like
to go to have a reasonable shot at the
world championship title he still has to
learn a lot he has to improve in many
areas as well so if i try to focus on
those things getting better in many
areas and
in all these games he's playing against
the strong players some issues keep
coming up every once in a while and we
try to address them
and get better in those areas so
basically we are focusing on making him
better
in as many areas as possible and a world
champion
yeah
thank you
thank you
it's fantastic to have ramesh such a
notable chess coach here in oslo of
course following prague we did have a
few moves the bar okay it's happening
stuff slightly on black side i don't
think it's a game-changing advantage
here there's still a lot of life left i
think it's just all to do with the kings
to be honest uh black's king if you
compare it with the white king super
safe just guarded by a wall of pawns
white king no matter which way it goes
this is what you said simon earlier
right no matter which way the white king
goes it's going to come under some heavy
fire and temporarily white is a pawn up
if we do a quick count but the pawn
structure is a bit weird both sides have
weaknesses
so i don't think the material here is so
important it's more important for king
safety and here i'm expecting jordan
maybe to bring his rook into the game
black's rook next to his king can come
to the open b file maybe the black
knight next to the black rook in the
center of the board can start jumping
around start trying to find ways into
white's position
also if we compare the queens both of
them are on the sides of the board but
white queen not really threatening
anything black's queen is just poised
looking
towards the white king making it feel
uncomfortable so just a lot of small
factors potentially adding up to that
black advantage that we see on the
evaluation bar but
jordan still needs to be accurate and
creative
maybe you can try to do a pawn break as
well at some point push one of the pawns
in the center of the board to try to
open up white's position even more
um black's pieces seem to have quite a
lot of potential those knights uh that
black has if he could start getting them
jumping around
could start creating some nasty threats
and the time situation well okay i mean
prague's still got enough time there i'd
say he's got enough time pride just
under six minutes but jordan 11 minutes
he must be enjoying this moment this is
a very jordan type of position as well
he loves to attack if he can he's not
materialistic in the slightest so and uh
well simon i have to tell you you asked
and twitter did answer so you said you
know your question was who do you think
jordan looks like i'm very interested
and ali reza sabach says chris pine
which i think is a good one oh is that
who is that again uh yeah he plays
wonder woman's uh boyfriend yeah chris
pine chris pine yeah yeah if you google
him he is oh wow there it is oh yes i
agree similarity uh joanne dwight he
says that jordan van faris looks like
zac efron what was the name that i heard
and i was wondering how did he get into
the conversation
and the black knight actually improves
itself and reza says jordan van forest
looks like richard madden from the
eternals i can see that okay somebody
get on madden i have to read up on my
celebrities some pretty good names isn't
it game of thrones as well yeah
well we thought sac efron we did yeah
yeah i mean he's got they were good
names weren't they you weren't my being
compared to any of them it wasn't like
shrek or something you know it's like
give him a good hollywood name you know
so they're handsome guys i also heard
someone yesterday mentioned nate
archibald from gossip girl yeah i kind
of agree on that one as well
celebrity
from forest
maybe it's all these celebrities looking
like you're from forest of course yes
that's right yes um and the game the
game still is still maneuvering about
here but um not much has changed david
not too much has changed no uh practice
trying to plug all the holes in the
white position with this light squared
bishop that light squared bishop alone
doing quite a good job actually of
covering squares but
still if it's that piece against all of
black's army it's not going to be easy i
think maybe prague's idea ideas the
white queen now does have a root back
maybe the white queen wants to park
herself in front of the king just to
protect everything jordan again just
this small window uh where he can start
to create threats maybe black is able to
overwhelm white
i still love bringing that black rook to
the b file if you have an open file why
not occupy it with a rook
um what else may be pushing pawns
forward to open up lines you advocated
for that simon this is the type of
position i would hate to have against
you
well i would hate to have the white
pieces because it just looks like the
white king is going to come under heavy
fire and i mean you might you might even
better go night knight takes pawn and
try to at some point throw it into you
know g3 uh but you know
on the edge of the board it looks like
it does have two harry's two harry's are
better than one yeah wow
yeah get get rid of that okay he's
played your move very very logical yeah
get another piece into the game do you
enjoy that having double harry's or is
it is double or harry's the better yeah
you know give me four give me five
i'll be a very happy man just put them
all on the hvac
i'd happily just push them all over
so actually i do prefer getting rid of
them i prefer like opening up the the
rook so i prefer like sacrificing the
poor guy uh he's a brave soldier
just get him out of the way
so
and i love that previous angle where we
could see the screen jordan has it full
screen his uh his board there and we saw
him drag the rook across i actually
heard a friend was telling me he gave me
a bit of advice for these online events
and he said i have quite a big screen at
home he said you have too big a board
it's just too big he said you should
have a small screen because it's further
to move the mouse right so when you're
when you're in time travel you have to
like you know i'm like bit old-school
i'm like dragging a mouse over here
dragging it back but i could be doing
this i could be like you know i'm saving
myself you know i'm getting a good
exercise but i'm doing too much arm
movement so i thought that was
interesting actually you know just have
a smaller screen but you're you're very
strong david at these online events i
mean you play a lot of them and
you go smaller stream as well so
especially a lot of the events i play
there'll be blitz or bullet chess where
you don't get any extra time after every
move so you need to save those extra
kind of milliseconds
um so yeah i very much prefer the
smaller boards but then again these
players they do gain 10 seconds after
every move so
i think moving the mouse uh they should
be used to them
yeah i mean at this at this top level
though this is the kind of thing the
players will be thinking about just tiny
margins because they're also good they
need to find the extra edge and uh
different players have different
preferences
meanwhile okay black's rook move onto
the b-file was met by white pushing
pawns forward so look how open both
flanks are that white king is not going
to be safe castling either side anytime
soon and jordan after a trade of knights
plonked his other knight into the center
of the board resulting in another trade
so white still won pawn up remember but
look at black's queen perfectly
centralized hitting white's rook in that
corner
and what to do about it white's rook
needs to move i don't think you really
want to castle here
um i like that suggestion as well yeah
nothing look alike
but yeah still despite what the
evaluation bar says prague is the one
answering the questions right now
and uh if you can answer them though
maybe black's running out of ammunition
the black rooks can't really get in the
game black's bishop not doing too much
yet
so uh trump still can go in either way
this game i mean there's one thing that
kind of just jumps out to me and that is
that the white queen is off on a limb
there on that square
and i'm just thinking if i were black
you know once white has defended the
rook maybe i would try and cut her off
yeah very interesting idea and just
bring the rook up
you can also try to get the black bishop
in
start creating some frets
i'd be more comfortable playing black
here because it's an easier position to
play when you've got this active queen
maybe as the computer indicates prague
is better but you've got to be very
accurate
in such a position one bad move with the
white pieces you lose you play one bad
move with black okay you can still
continue so it's
more pressurized for prague to find the
right moves here yeah just to show your
ideas this black rook move would cut off
the white queen's kind of route back to
safety back to protect her king
there's still a lot of calculation to be
done for example in this position you
have to calculate what happens if white
pushes forward and white goes on the
attack i'm not quite sure it's working
because white isn't attacking with too
many pieces and black is perfectly
centralized here but either way
interesting uh concept and the other one
simon mentioned bringing the bishop into
the game would actually create a threat
due to this pin of queen takes pawn a
deadly check
so definitely lots of ideas and prague
actually spending more time here he's
down to three minutes against nine can
he try to move his king and get
centralized as queen cause i remember in
the first game oh he hasn't done that
he's just moved his rook okay really
clever simon maybe moving the king
forward and uh just connecting the rooks
and making them defend i'm learning for
you david you did say
you know get the queen in the center
keep it solid so that's what i was
trying to do get the queens off prague
wasn't listening though that proves the
wars are sound proof here
maybe he just thinks we're rubbish
probably more likely
he hears our suggestions and he thinks
okay anything apart from yes that's
right none of those moves and uh okay
black's bishop just on this square so
actually uh kind of nullifying the white
bishop on this diagonal
yeah
maybe the other pawn break as well you
know maybe preparing this one or this
one
okay
there are some definite ideas but simon
and i were surprised because it did look
like maybe bringing the rook forward was
more dynamic and more aggressive uh
instead this move
a bit of defense a bit of attack i'm
expecting white now to either bring the
queen back or maybe
whoa okay he brings his rook forward
attacking the black queen and the reason
i reacted there is because it does allow
a check in the corner this looks a bit
nasty but then again you can maybe just
block with your queen you can bring your
queen the whole way back and uh just
offer a trade because white is a point
up after all white has these double
harrys
the double harry's very nice all right
this one yeah young pregnant who won the
first one he is up by one point in the
match magnus carlsen he won the first
game against duda he started out with a
very strange opening in game two we're
curious to hear if that was
a mouse slip or if he had planned
something very strange we'll take a look
at that later the bar though is still
over to young christopher do the side in
that game hansen and geary they played a
draw in the first game and a quick draw
in game two still tied eric hansen and
anish agiri and liam lee and shakhrian
mamdiarov they played the draw in game
one and in this one i think the bar is
lately over to uh mom liaro's side could
he be about to win with the black pieces
that would be a great result for him but
we are following pragnanda against
jordan from forest as we see shakria and
mumbli are
in deep thought deep concentrations
looking very good in the oslo arena
against
liam lee
button fanfare is now starting to think
as well do you think jordan is keeping a
close eye on prague's clock trying to
just surprise him to spend even more
time yeah it's human nature to have one
eye at least on your opponent's time
you've got to make sure that you don't
if your decisions aren't affected too
much for example you don't start just
playing subpar moves inferior moves just
to try and trick your opponent because
if your moves aren't good after all your
opponent does gain 10 seconds after
every move they will maybe neutralize
you maybe just refute your ideas and uh
and win so you've got to find that
balance tricky chess but also strong
chess and uh yeah he'll try and get
prague to think but the clock isn't yet
critical for prague okay jordan instead
jumps in with his queen attacking
white's bishop which retreats to a
defended square so prague was actually
thinking in jordan's time there very
good stuff and he keeps everything
defended
black's queen looks great to be honest
but what to do next that's the question
yeah black doesn't have many open lines
that's the problem i mean you've got one
active piece and prague is defending
very well here luckily his pawns block
up the position which is which is very
useful for him when he's got the extra
pawn stopping blacks rooks getting in uh
to the game here so uh yeah black's
bishop as well just staring at a wall at
once yeah that's so surprising
i'm a little bit surprised as well
because it does look very attractive to
put the queen there uh the black queen
that is on that particular square but at
the same time prague pragnanz's move is
great because the rook is threatening to
attack it and whoops i saw zac efron
shaking his head
yeah i mean if i was zach here i'd
probably unleash unleash c5 or something
i think about a move like this i don't
think it works but you've got to look at
breaks like this i think that was his
plan actually maybe jordan wanted to
push the sea pawn i said you're down
whoops but yeah
but white's rook in the corner would
have actually come across two squares
hit the black queen and uh yeah the
black queen she dived into the position
she realized there was nothing to do and
now she's retreated so maybe jordan is
just losing a move there and this time
be a big loss as well because he lost
the first game so
if jordan loses this one he can only
draw uh at the end of the four games so
it's important yeah
yeah yeah jordan
zac efron going for those white h pawns
now black's queen wants to go across and
capture some of those pawns but i think
prague has a really important move here
a really nice simple move as well bring
the white queen the whole way back
parker there we go in front of the white
king and actually that white queen
indirectly defends those white pawns on
the right side uh if the black queen had
gone across and taken those pawns
white's rook would have jumped out the
way with the check and black would have
lost a queen so you wouldn't do the
right thing opening things up this is
what he has to do but still prague in
control and he's either listening to
music prague or he's just really happy
with his position yeah he's rocking back
and forth it looks good for white yeah
yeah i mean he's in less danger now
especially because there's been so many
trades on the board and i do like what
jordan is doing you know putting the
rooks on open lines he's getting ready
to double the rooks put pressure against
the white bishop
but i do think that jordan is now just
uh
he's trying to get the compensation
to survive as opposed to before when he
was pleasant pleasantly better yeah and
now that king is also trying to find a
safer place so there's not really many
weaknesses in white's position now that
that's the problem previously and there
were some issues with the black queen
coming in but now you know where is the
weakness um and it is an extra pawn at
the end of the day yeah and uh that's a
really classy move this last king move
at the very minimum as well white's
bishop can kind of drop back to the
square the king previously sat on just
defend everything i love my bishops on
those squares there's just no
breakthrough for the opponent and
yeah the longer jordan is upon down
now that there's no direct attack the
more uncomfortable
he will feel and if the queen's come off
i think white will win this game
so uh queen trade benefits white rook
trades probably help white as well
bishop trades i'm not 100 sure but uh
either way prague he's he's kind of up
the speed and he's looking very very
confident
if prague wins actually uh just got a
message from our stats genius tai saying
that if prague wins this game his tour
rating will pass 2700 for the very first
time
and that would be a great number for
young prague yeah wow he's heading in
that that direction in classical chess
as well he's already
hardly fit in the seat can he yeah
you know he sort of seems to be just
just there bro yeah yeah when i first
played him his feet barely touched the
floor he still beat me he became an
international master at the age of 10
years old and that's just incredible he
was the youngest international master
ever
and uh jordan is really kind of
struggling a little bit in this position
one thing that i just wanted to point
out is that jordan shouldn't be in a big
rush to try to win back material like
for instance
you know move the bishop from its
central location to attack the rook and
the pawn because whilst that does look
like yes you get some something back on
the other hand your bishop is out on a
limb it's in the middle of no man's land
so once the rook moves bishop takes porn
well the bishop is doing nothing and can
maybe even get trapped
yeah and suddenly white can go on the
attack white's bishop can step forward
maybe hitting this pawn in conjunction
with the rook and as ivanka mentions
this bishop is just a bystander now you
definitely don't want to kind of
uh poorly coordinate your pieces you
don't want to just strand one of your
own pieces on the wrong side of the
board away from the rest of your army so
yeah we're not expecting that move and
also to point out the other one this
pawn looks like it's up for grabs but it
cannot be captured because rook takes
pawn is a check and also what we could
uh call a discovered attack hitting the
black queen so after the king for
example takes the rook back queen takes
queen and white will win so okay nothing
to do with that queen after all black
just steps back with her and uh knowing
jordan it's mostly because he wants to
push pawns he wants to kind of initiate
some play maybe kick away this strong
white rook but
retreating is never a good sign maybe
white now uh can just move this bishop
to a safe square
maybe the white king can okay the bishop
does indeed drop back uh i highlighted
this one earlier just as a very safe
move look how everything protects each
other now and at some point white can
start thinking of trading off the queens
it's looking good still for prague one
point up and that's why the computer
says roughly plus one advantage for
white
yeah
seeing all these uh suggestions for uh
lookalikes for jordan buffers that's uh
popular simon your suggestion to ask for
lookalikes for jordan forest many people
agree with us he looks like zac efron do
you guys have any uh celebrity
lookalikes
i i tried this thing where it kind of
gives you your celebrity look alike
and then it gave me a man i was not
impressed
so i was like okay i'm not doing this
how about you guys
you have one david you do he's an
english comedian called phil wang and uh
i i got mistaken for him once on the
underground on the metro uh in england
some a group of girls came up to me they
were like oh we uh well done today you
were really great and i just come from a
chess tournament so i was like oh thanks
i won the chess tournament i was feeling
pretty proud of myself
and then they asked for a selfie and
afterwards they were like oh thanks phil
gave a good selfie that's cool
yeah it turns out he's actually
interchanged as well oh that's cool
didn't he tweet or something as well
yeah he tweeted about chess and uh we've
been chatting on twitter
that's cool and you have one as well
simon well maybe a little bit like is it
giant spain yes like um who's he was
yeah he's he's got longer hair than me
but he's he's a great actor so uh
yeah very cool guy
thrones game of from
and he's norwegian right as well so he
is yeah he's a really good actor so it's
not bad yeah i'll take that and you're
looking as well we had him as a guest as
well on our
charity challenge last season i mean
while a couple of moves white's king has
run away to safety but in the meantime
black has used that
a couple of
that use that tempe to go and grab some
pawns with his queen so now black's
queen restored material parity by
grabbing a pawn she's also attacking
white's rook at the bottom of the board
i guess prague has an idea here what is
it is he just going to move that rook
challenge black's kind of control over
the open file or is he going to jump
forward and gain time against this black
bishop suddenly the black queen earlier
ivanka you mentioned black bishop
doesn't want to end up on that square
because it's a terrible square suddenly
the back black queen is on that uh on
that post and yeah
this is quite quite a thread for black
yeah it's quite a normal way to try to
transfer one type of advantage to
another and uh this seems to be what
white's done here is he's really given
that pawn up to activate his pieces um
and okay where is the well the queen has
to go to the square only one square that
black queen had to go here simon
mentioned because she has to also defend
her bishop in the center of the board
from white's rook on the fifth rank uh
so now offering a queen trade to trade
or not to trade what do you guys think
i mean
i if you do trade you'd want something
concrete um in the position you want to
you want to try to win material or get
something um quite big out of the
position um who's attacking i mean
it feels like white has this
open line against the black king so if
you are attacking generally you want to
keep the queens on the board but i can't
really see a great square to move that
queen
i mean maybe towards the king side oh
wow
kick the queens on yeah yeah maybe i
mean yeah maybe keep the queens on i was
about to say i thought i saw a tricky
tactic it doesn't quite work uh bringing
white's rook to the center for the board
breaking connection but okay the queen
trade did happen prague under one minute
maybe that influenced his decision to
trade the queens keeping the queens on
more ambitious but also maybe more risky
uh so okay a queen trade and now will
white start to try and target those two
weak black pawns
on the queen side on that left side
and there we see jordan is he going to
start pre-moving he's got three minutes
a lot of time
will he be dragging the black bishop
back into the game next move prague
pushing a pawn forward i was going to
say there is a tactical idea behind this
one if we see a trade of pawns white's
rook will recapture and
the white bishop at the bottom of the
board actually wants to come over to the
square the rook currently stands on look
at the two black rooks they're both on
dart squares white's bishop can attack
them both at the same time
if given the opportunity so prague uh
setting up a trap here jordan has to be
really careful
yeah definitely uh jordan has to be
tread with caution but i'm not a fan of
this move actually because you know that
pawn that advanced itself the b pawn
well
it was kind of holding the black pawns
at bay and they were it was making them
weaknesses if jordan manages to
eliminate this pawn without
getting into danger
then i think the position will probably
peter out into a draw yeah the question
for jordan now is he's feeling pretty
safe the queens are off he's one point
down in today's match is he going to
even try and win this one somehow i
don't see how to be honest yet but
if we do see a trade of pawns for
example if he can somehow trade off all
the rooks and just keep one extra pawn
for black on this left side
long term maybe some chances for him um
jordan every time i play him even if
it's an end game even if it's a dead
draw he's always looking for small
tricks here and there and now down to
two minutes he needs to move i kind of
agree with you though ivanka this move
that um prague played i mean it looks
really scary but it's the kind of move
that either works or it doesn't work
it's kind of moved that you probably
wouldn't see magnus carlsen play right i
mean he he would only
change the position if it has a very big
effect i mean
but saying that what does black do i'm
not entirely sure
uh maybe you could just trade off a set
of pawns here and then drop black bishop
back to the c3 square just try and trade
off the bishops just try to swap yeah if
you can trade off the bishops as black i
think you're completely safe yeah um
even if you end up with one few pawn on
if you separate the boards into hearts
right now on the right half of the board
white has a four versus three advantage
but doubled pawns if it's just rooks
they're not that great
so i think that would be the safety
first option for jordan
maybe he's looking for more that's why i
was saying if he's feeling ambitious
he'll look for something else i think
that's like the backup plan for him but
suddenly the clock situation you're also
down to one minute
yeah and often that favors the side
who's been in time trouble for longer um
just as a time trouble added to myself
my whole career often i'm low on one
minute for the whole game but i'm in
that rhythm i'm used to playing quickly
someone who's had an hour on their clock
the whole time as soon as they get down
to one minute they panic because they're
not in that uh
in that same flow so okay we do see a
trade of pawns and
now the bishop does drop back
and uh okay this trade means that the
game most likely is heading towards a
draw white has a small advantage because
black has a weakness over on this left
side of the wood i don't think that pawn
is so great yes it's a past pawn
but uh
what do you think guys i mean it should
be a draw right i mean uh yeah i think
so i mean if black manages to swap off a
set of rooks i think it will be an easy
draw well with the presence of all rooks
on the board i think maybe
prague can uh have some fun and grind
try and grind it out yeah we saw on
jordan's screen he's about to push a
pawn okay he made it just as i was about
to say he was about to push a pawn next
to his king to create some lift create
some air for that black king
uh in order to escape no background
checkmates anymore but this does mean
he's abandoning all hope uh on the queen
side that black pawn is about to fall
first prague goes and attacks upon
himself
and uh
okay giving up a pawn but black's idea
is to bring one of his rooks back to the
fifth rank later and look at harry the
h-born he's not it's not so easy to hold
this i mean because white white has uh
this pawn in the middle of the board the
e pawn
and when you've got where you're pawn up
for a start but you can use that pawn at
some point to to roll down the board um
jordan hanging onto his pawn now though
um can he save that pawn i don't think
so but well maybe he has
yeah and uh it's not just about whether
this black pawn will fall it's just
about whether the other black rook can
get active when it does fall and start
targeting white's weak h pawns and one
thing about rook and games is computers
often say white has a small advantage
even if it's just a dead draw so um yes
white might end up with an extra pawn
but white's four versus three on the
right half of the board
is so hard to create a possible one but
i like simon's idea though of uh slowly
pushing forward
with the central pawn and uh trying to
open up the seventh line yeah
and uh we do we should listen to david
no i don't know i mean i i mean i agree
i mean
you'd have to play on with white because
you are a paulo yeah so you've got to
make it as tricky as you can but at the
end of the day probably just a draw he's
given up all hope yeah prague of winning
now black's pawn did fall but look white